a pure tone is a vibration of air back
and forth at a certain frequency and it
sounds like this if you want to raise
the pitch of that tone you can speed up
those vibrations but because you've
spread the vibrations up that tone
doesn't last as long slow it down and
that tone will go on for longer pitch
correction or auto-tune is clever when
it changes a note that someone's not
quite sound correctly it changes the
speed of the vibrations but it also adds
or remove some vibrations so the
duration stays the same except that's
not quite the full answer because
musical notes don't sound like this they
sound like
[Music]
ladies gentlemen all in between the
Gregory Brothers hell pitch correction
actually girls
but my degrees in linguistics replace
them with this buzzer the secret is math
called Fourier transform it takes the
frequencies that were two twined splits
them up identifies them isolates them
then software could change the line in
real-time the supplicant change to the
notes inside of God you can do pianos
guitars
to me it's all offense it might as well
magic but it can't write song some
talent still required oh yeah
[Music]
and we're wandering off but other that
sounded pretty good as it's a powerful
no actually